la colline d'lancour deviendra-t-elle
enfin une colline olympique le projet
dans les cartons depuis les j de 2012 a
été ressorti pour la candidature de
Paris au Jio de 2024 le site qui culmine
à 231 m d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de VTT la
première force c'est l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivélation et donc le VTT on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il y a qu qu'ici
qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on souhaite
pour avoir quelque chose de très raide
donc ouais c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
rangeche pour rendre ce site totalement
opérationnel pour les Jeux Olympiques
quelques travaux sont nécessaires dans
ce lieu à l'état presque sauvage des
tribunes seront construite en amont de
la colline les organisateurs vont
également devoir façonner un parcours
entre 4 et 6 km avec des sentiers des
secteurs goudronés des parties en
sous-bois pour répondre au cahier des
charges cet aménagement c'est pas pour
construire he c'est vraiment pour mod
lait donc on va on le fait avec avec des
des rochers de la pierre avec du Gor
avec avec également des Tron d'arbres on
est vraiment dans du modelage donc on
peut le faire avec des des produits sur
place avec avec des gravass également le
VTT reste quand même une discipline de
pleine nature et on joue avec ce que
l'on a ce qu' l'on a sous les pieds pour
construire ce parcours d'une durée d'
1h30 les organisateur pourrai s'appuyer
sur les clubs locaux et notamment le
Vélo Club hlancours saquentin liveline
organisateur de la en charge une épreuve
de VTT qui fêtera cette année ses 19 ans
on a notre idée sur les aspects
techniques mais j'espère qu'on pourra
solliciter les acteurs locaux on a des
clubs qui sont mobilisés des clubs
locaux qui dans dans la pratique du VTT
sont sont également très présents et ils
connaissent mieux les lieux que que
n'importe qui ici donc certainement
qu'ils doivent bien les connaître et
donc c'est ça sera un plus de s'appuyer
sur sur leur connaissance du du terrain
le coût total de l'aménagement de la
colline d'éencour pour les GEOS n'est
pas encore connu si le CIO désigne la
France en septembre prochain les
premiers coups de pioche pourraient être
donnés d'ici